bio 14 points a dozen rebounds seven  assists and he's still  working at him good hustle by band love  the fact that he almost tied up  oh reggie jackson's upset he called  timeout just as  jenna schroeder were was calling a foul  on miami i don't believe the clippers  had a timeout left jackson is beside  himself  you got to be aware of how many you have  boy he's losing his cool over there on  the sideline right now  sir chewbacca providing comfort and  solace  let's watch his hands right here he's  calling timeout  that's that's the correct call by the  official that'll be a technical foul and  it'll get free throw and an opportunity  to to get possession  that tells you something about reggie  jackson how serious how personal he  takes us  sure does now look great position here  they still